il a traversé l'atlantique à la voile en
moins de huit jours c'est un formidable
exploit qui a réalisé lionel lemonchois
le skipper normand est arrivé tôt ce
matin à pointe-à-pitre qu'il a remporté
la huitième route du rhum en pulvérisant
le record de l'épreuve de plus de 4
jours
didier show man lionel lemonchois en
habit de lumière heureux comme un
quadrille de savourer enfin des qui
dresse cette victoire express sur
l'autoroute du rhum le marais normand
est apparu plutôt détendu ranger rasés
de près pour aller à la rencontre de ses
nombreux admirateurs venus lui rendre
hommage sur la ligne d'arrivée est un
rêve quoi depuis la route du rhum et 10
c est toutefois garder ses courses
ce bijou dû faire peut-être même tous
les départs c'est vrai que
imaginez un jour la sphère déjà c'était
pas mal mais alors en plus la gagner
c'est c'est incroyable coiffe ce marin
de référence a écrit un étonnant
scénario sur cette route du rhum en
survolant les flots de l'atlantique une
cadence infernale près de 40 km heure de
moyenne depuis le départ de saint malo
un rythme d'enfer terrorisé par de très
bonnes conditions météo
il pulvérise le record de l'épreuve
détenu par laurent bourgnon de plus de
quatre jours sept jours et 17 heures
pour traverser l'atlantique
chapeau l'étonnant ce bateau paillis
coll
il navigue pas y vole marché à 35,35
sous pilote dans la mer au portant sous
gennak il m'a jamais fait j'avais fait
moindre coût de temps du jour hyper
simple jours
c'est génial lionel lemonchois
impressionné tous ses adversaires il
peut désormais être fier de ce qu'il
vient d'accomplir
lui qui a toujours vécu dans l'ombre des
plus grands marins préparateur hors pair
ce skipper réservé a souvent été recruté
pour ses compétences
pendant cette traversée il aura vécu une
histoire fusionnelle avec son trimaran
aujourd'hui dans la lumière il est
obligé de sortir de sa réserve pour
apprécier enfin ce beau moment
d'excellence
et
oui